mais bien évidemment un soldat famille
est proche ont tenu à se rassembler au
cimetière de La Verrière ce 19 mars pour
ne pas oublier les victimes civiles et
militaires de la guerre d'Algérie la
date de commémoration divise mais cette
journée nationale du souvenir et du
recueillement et pour la première fois
officielle 51 années après le CC le feu
c'est surtout pour les anciens
combattants mais moi je suis veuve
d'ancien combattants et c'est une
reconnaissance et l'officialisation
depuis la fin de la guerre d'Algérie que
tous les anciens combattants attendaient
pour l'occasion la FNACA de Maurepas qui
fête ses 40 ans cette année a mis en
place une exposition de témoignages
intitulé nos vingt ans en Afrique du
Nord à l'étage de l'hôtel de ville de
Maurepas les premiers tableaux évoquent
le départ des soldats de Marseille pour
l'Algérie la découverte des paysages et
de la vie des bédouins mais pas
seulement
on voit des photos de des interventions
qui sont qui interviennent par exemple
dans les gorges de Palestro on aperçoit
également les comment dirais-je les la
pacification on voit également
capacification c'était aussi la guerre
mais c'était aussi le service de l'armée
auprès des populations
des services comme les soins médicaux
Gérald descoff a été appelé pour la
pacification de mars 1956 à mars 1958
dans le groupe d'hélicoptère numéro 2
avec un lieutenant médecin il faisait
des tournées dans les villages isolés
ils se souvient
des lampes à pétrole et une fois il y a
la lampe a été renversée et la petite
fille a été très très gravement brûlé
qui a permis pas d'intermédiaire des
hélicoptères bien sûr de l'emmener tout
de suite à l'hôpital de Sétif et je l'ai
revu un an après qui était sauvé
l'exposition de la Fnac à Maurepas se
termine ce samedi